now it is so much easier to prevent
cancer than to try to reverse cancer
once you have it and out of all the
conditions that someone can get
medically cancer is probably the most
scary the prognosis is not good the
treatment is very invasive so today
we're going to talk about
the prevention of cancer but if you have
cancer there is something you can do as
well i'm going to put some links down
below but an ounce of prevention is
worth a pound of cure
but
only if you have the correct information
about
prevention i mean how are you going to
prevent cancer if you're
operating off of the wrong information
so today i'm going to share with you
some quality
knowledge that potentially could help
avoid cancer so first of all what causes
cancer what causes cancer is damage to
your mitochondria then what happens this
normal cell
converts over to a cancer cell so it's
not like an invasion of a
um an infection a virus
it's a situation where your cells are
damaged
and
your body through a survival mechanism
converts over to a cancer cell so it
originates from a normal cell and so
this new cancer cell is very um kind of
prehistoric it's very crude it loses its
mortality
it can actually now live forever and so
the metabolism of cancer is completely
different from the metabolism of a
normal cell
its rate of consuming sugar is much
higher than a normal cell and the other
interesting thing about cancer is that
it spreads into areas of inflammation so
it can become malignant and spread into
areas that you had trauma mechanical
injury or for example let's say you're a
smoker and you have chronic inflammation
your lungs it can spread in that area or
let's say there's chronic inflammation
in the gut that happen from eating the
wrong foods then the cancer can spread
to that area as well so it's really
important to understand that anything
that can create damage in your
mitochondria can also cause cancer and
there's also other things that are
emphasized
at the wrong level of importance so it's
really valuable to know
what is really important versus what is
not as important when you're trying to
prevent cancer so i think everyone knows
smoking usually causes cancer to your
lungs
but smoking can also
cause cancer to your pancreas in fact
one of the biggest causes of pancreatic
cancer is smoking which is kind of
interesting because you would think that
it would only affect the lungs but it
can affect the pancreas as well and of
course the chronic consumption of
alcohol can cause cancer okay i think
most people know that and then of course
they talk about obesity as being a risk
factor well um okay is it obesity itself
or is it a diet that created obesity
like a diet that has uh frequent meals
so six meals a day causing a lot of
snacking so the combination of both
frequent eating and high carbs can
increase your risk of getting obese and
so in reality
i wouldn't say that obesity in itself
causes cancer but those things that
cause obesity definitely increase cancer
especially
too much insulin when you have high
levels of insulin your risks for cancer
go way up and so now it's important to
understand what causes an insulin spike
well a lot of refined carbohydrates and
sugar as well as eating frequent meals
and then of course on the flip side of
that what about fasting what about
intermittent fasting what does that do
for cancer well it does a lot it's
probably the most important thing you
can do if you get cancer in fact there's
two cases that i know right now that
were both stage four terminal cancer and
both of these people did fasting and
completely went in remission with cancer
i mean the doctors were just dumbfounded
i did an interview with one of the
gentlemen which i'll put a link down
below i mean it's quite amazing to go
from a stage four to
not having any stages of cancer that's
that's incredible and the most important
thing to do prolonged fasting and both
of these individuals were not smokers
they were not drinkers so the question
is what caused their cancer well we're
going to go through some things now
right now if you actually do a research
on
decreasing your risk factor for cancer
you'll see that
saturated fat
causes cancer or it's linked to cancer
and so they're recommending that you
should replace your saturated fat
with unsaturated fat
okay so this right here is very very bad
advice
and all the things i talk about today
i'm going to put research down below so
you can
cross-reference these studies but the
quality of studies that they did for fat
are basically questionnaire studies very
very poor quality
very inconclusive to say that saturated
fat alone
increases your risk of getting cancer
there are so many other variables that
it could be when you're doing this
questionnaire type study so as far as
the unsaturated fats you have omega-3
and then you have omega-6 fatty acids
omega-3 fatty acids are very
anti-inflammatory so that would greatly
improve inflammation which could
decrease the risk of getting cancer
right there
but then omega-6 fatty acids
the
corn oils the soy oil cottonseed oil the
other unsaturated fatty acids
that people are telling you to eat more
of and replace the saturated fats well
those have direct links of increasing
inflammation but there's also some
credible data that shows that when you
consume these seed oils that are heated
as in frying something greatly increase
your risk of getting cancer and i'll put
that data down below now what about mono
unsaturated fats like
avocado oil or olive oil well those show
some pretty good anti-cancer effects so
those are pretty safe but personally
i've not seen any credible data that
shows in any way that saturated fats are
linked to
increasing your risk of getting cancer
now what about trans fats yes there is
some big links
between trans fats and increasing risk
of cancer so to simplify what i'm going
to talk about is the more refined
something is the more chemically
processed something is like the
vegetable oils for example where they're
using all sorts of chemicals and high
heat and pressure to refine them
the more something will increase the
risk of getting cancer now let's shift
to another topic that relates to this
red meat and processed meat they kind of
lump these two together
saying that both of these will increase
your risk of getting cancer but we
really have to differentiate them
because
you also have a lot of
white processed meat okay not just red
processed meat and also you have to look
at how many of these studies were based
on a questionnaire
probably all of them and also you have
to look at the quality of this red meat
did they do the study on grass-fed grass
finish red meat
no they haven't did they differentiate
when you're eating red meat alone or
with some other carbohydrate like french
fries for example did they differentiate
the red meat from mcdonald's versus red
meat from the farm the answer is no
now the thing that's in processed meat
is a lot of chemicals a lot of refining
a lot of things added so it's pretty
much obvious that
if you're eating red meat at a fast food
restaurant it's highly processed and
refined now this also chronic crosses
over
to processed foods okay because when
we're looking at refined foods or ultra
refined foods
it's in the family of a lot of processed
meat and refined carbohydrates and
chemicals and the combination with
adding a protein with sugar or a fat
with sugar with high heats okay as in
french fries
chips and they might have a little bit
of whole wheat flour in there that's so
badly processed that you cannot say that
whole grains will help prevent cancer so
when you see some study that shows that
whole wheat grain reduces your cancer
risk
look at the whole picture actually read
it in fact i've never heard anyone just
eating whole grains they usually have it
with a bunch of other things but the
problem is when you take this processed
food especially refined grains
and you add it with heat
and you add it with certain vegetable
oils
you get what's called acrylamide okay
acrylamide is a known carcinogen so
again without getting too complex we
want to avoid refined foods we want to
avoid processed foods of course
we want to look at the quality of whole
foods
and this relates to the next thing i
want to talk about which is fiber
you'll see this all the time where well
if you increase your fiber you're going
to decrease your risk of cancer now
they're lumping in
all the different types of fiber with
vegetable fiber
what about all these new synthetic
fibers that they're coming out with
they're called
functional fibers
like resistant maltodextrin like tapioca
fiber like corn fiber these are all very
new fibers that have not stood the time
of safety studies we don't really know
about them they may not affect your
blood sugars
but
i found some interesting data i want to
share with you so adding highly refined
fiber to processed foods
could have some negative effects on your
health such as promoting liver cancer
according to a new study
researchers at georgia state university
and the university of toledo future
studies will certainly be needed to
disentangle the harmful from the
beneficial aspects of gut fermentation
in fact they found a significant amount
of these mice in the study developed
liver cancer
now you might say well wait a second
mice are different than humans but
there's really been no safety studies on
humans so to start putting all these
functional fibers
in
a lot of the foods that you eat right
now
including a lot of the so-called keto
friendly bars and snacks etc i think is
very premature so yes they might not
have an effect on your blood sugar
but what kind of effect do they have on
your gut microbiome and so again to
simplify this
you want to consume fiber
from actual food not some synthetic
fiber
that is added to your food now since
we're on the topic of synthetic i want
to uh now mention
antioxidants right there's some
conflicting information that says that
antioxidant supplements actually cause
cancer right now wait a second i thought
that antioxidants
prevented cancer well what you might not
know is the studies that they're basing
this on
involve using synthetic
antioxidants not the antioxidants that
you would get from food
let's for example take beta carotene
beta carotene is a carotenoid it's a fat
soluble antioxidant
and it has a lot of great benefits but
apparently it's being put in our foods
it's being put in
infant formula as vitamin a it's being
used to
color
uh farm-raised salmon to give it that
pink color because if you didn't it
would be gray
it's also been used in commercial eggs
to color the egg yolks to make them look
really good
because if they didn't you wouldn't have
the color well you might say well it's
just a beta-carotene it's just an
antioxidant it's not going to cause any
issue but if you've done the deep dive
into how they make beta-carotene
synthetically
wow they had all sorts of chemicals
it's made from acetone
using different solvents like hexane
all to make this coloring agent right so
there's a really big difference between
a synthetic something and a natural it's
not the same thing and the problem is
there's links to increased risk of
getting cancer and the reason i'm
bringing this up is because we're
talking about decreasing the risks of
cancer right and so all antioxidants you
might think are good but well only those
that come from nature so again to
simplify this you want to eat real food
you don't want to do synthetic versions
of food and you want to get your
antioxidants from
vegetables now since we're talking about
antioxidants i want to talk about
probably the most
powerful antioxidants and that would be
melatonin okay melatonin definitely
decreases your risk of getting cancer
now melatonin is a sleep hormone but it
also has another function
in all of your cells
and it can act as an antioxidant and the
way that you increase
melatonin is to be exposed to infrared
light so when you're out in the sun
you get a tremendous amount of infrared
that actually can penetrate your clothes
and it goes right into your body
at least two inches
and all this infrared can recharge and
increase melatonin which is a very
powerful antioxidant
now this might be confusing to you
because you've been taught to stay out
of the sun because the sun is bad and it
will increase your risk of getting a
cancer well this is another topic that's
completely distorted and there's a lot
of misinformation so let me just clarify
that
when you're out in the sun
okay you have
uv light okay and it's the uvb
type of light that will help you
increase vitamin d and vitamin d is
another thing that can greatly decrease
your risk of getting cancer but on top
of that the uv
light stimulates
your melanocytes the cells that make
melanin
and melanin
acts like an umbrella it's like a
natural sunscreen it's protection
against the harmful
radiation of uv light so understanding
that it's important that you don't let
yourself get completely burned but you
can just expose yourself to a certain
amount of light and so you get a tan and
not get totally burnt and maybe you
gradually increase the dosage of sun
you can actually decrease the risk of
that uv radiation there are some real
interesting studies which i'll include
down below that shows that being out in
the sun decrease your risk of getting
certain types of cancer especially
prostate cancer and the so-called
credible research studies that shows
that sun increases your risk of getting
melanoma
is very very weak and a very poor
association
so a certain amount of sun exposure can
help you
decrease the risk of cancer and a lot of
other
chronic health conditions number one
from the vitamin d number two from all
the melatonin that you're going to
generate from that also antioxidants
from cruciferous vegetables if you
consume
just three servings of cruciferous
vegetables
every single week you can decrease your
risk of certain types of cancer by up to
40 i mean that's incredible then you
have exercise right exercise has been a
known proven activity to decrease your
risk of cancer so this video might have
been a little bit all over the place but
in the description i i put bullet points
of all the things that you should focus
on but in order to prevent cancer you
need the correct information now i think
it's really appropriate for you to check
out this amazing interview that i did
with this gentleman who had stage four
cancer and now he doesn't check it out i
put it right here
you